I don't know it's a magical time of year  when Stefani is already spreading the  Christmas cheer I love it I love  Christmas while promoting her new  holiday album you make it feel like  Christmas at the Grove in LA on Friday  Stefani treated her fans with a pop-up  shop including a special meet-and-greet  pop star glittered in gold while posing  for photos with her adoring fans Minnie  waited in line for hours just to get a  glimpse of Gwynn up close including this  fan who showed off her arm tattoo of  Gwen's face but this wee moment with a  little girl will melt your heart  [Music]  safe to say Gwyn made a ton of wishes  come true thank you for for the love  that I have all around me right now I'm  so I'm so full of love  [Music]  you